we had someone on Twitter what I'm not
even sure who it was when we put out
there that we'd be interviewing with
someone who produces reality shows and
writes them and this person wrote back
quote why did you sell out and decide to
produce more garbage when there's so
many great shows that need to be made
but if the audience is telling you that
they want to watch some of this stuff
why do we interpret it as garbage okay
here's my answer to that reality
television when people are talking about
reality television that they perceive to
be garbage they are looking at very
specific types of reality television
they are not looking at Anthony Bourdain
they are not looking at dirty jobs they
are not looking at shows that are
interesting or informative or
inspirational or and reality is much
bigger than docu-series docu soaps and
that's all that anybody's talking about
when they're talking about producing
garbage docu-series docu soaps if you
take a look back into the earliest days
of television television from you know
the 1940s into the early 1950s was still
very experimental people were putting
plays on television and just shooting
them as if they were plays they were
doing all kinds of crazy things and
trying to find their footing and trying
to find what worked on television
docu-series dokey soaps have not been
around that long and if you look at it
if we started Becky series docu soaps
you know even in the 90s we're still
learning and there's going to be a lot
of product that's not that great and I
would defy anyone who talks about
reality television uniformly as garbage
to show me one hundred percent of the
scripted shows that have gone to air and
not identify absolute crap amongst those
shows of the very any creative endeavor
is very very hit-or-miss they're going
to be hits they're going to be failures
they're going to be shows that catch
people's interest and shows that dump
and to claim that reality television is
just producing garbage is an
extraordinarily narrow view and while I
wouldn't want to take that person on and
just call it an antagonist I would urge
them to start watching some more of the
things that are on
discovery on history watching Anthony
Bourdain's shows watching an idiot
abroad which is one of the best shows
I've seen on television in years and
just really kind of broadening what
their definition of their understanding
of what reality really is do you think
that people envision it's sort of that
the cat fights amongst the women or that
some of the backbiting that they see and
write that as being what all reality TV
is I'll tell you like there's a this is
a great example is I have i'm aware of a
series that i won't name the series ran
i think 14 episodes in the season there
were two on camera physical altercations
over the course of the full season which
were not full on fists it was just sort
of you know someone it was like flipping
a table over or like throwing a drink at
someone all that anybody talked about
the whole season were those huge
explosive moments I do think that people
when they think of reality television
again because the more sensational stuff
is what grabs headlines they tend to
think of reality in terms of those cat
fights because that's what the networks
are choosing to push in the promos
that's what's getting people to watch
it's the loud thing that's going to
bring you in I can go back to when I was
much younger and watching TV shows like
dynasty and here you know here's Joan
Collins and Linda Evans wrestling each
other into a fountain and nobody seems
to mind if it happens in scripted but if
it happens in an unscripted program
that's just totally unacceptable right
reality TV is much broader than just you
know people clawing at each other right
I think I saw that episode one
you